my first job uh i was paid 70 bucks per
month
um so that was a 500 a month
yeah
that was a fun uh fun uh fun part i
think now the salaries in i.t
in romania at least are
on average a bit higher than uh than
spain
for example so
the the level of demand is at an all
times high
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel an in media
partnership with ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
going to romania meet marius hanganu
managing partner of tremend
marios has been a manager in the
software industry for over 20 years he
has been overseeing complex projects
from sales to deployment and support he
serves as the managing partner of
tremend with a focus on operations and
shaping the organization to become a top
software romanian provider and he's well
on his way meet marius
mario zangano welcome to 20 minute
leaders all the way from romania how are
you
good nice to meet you michael good to be
here
it is nice to meet you too i'm looking
forward to hearing both about your
journey and also about the romanian
ecosystem and about this idea of
software development as a service and
you're the managing partner of
tremendous software consulting i believe
over the last 15 years you've done more
than 700 projects worldwide which is an
unfathomable amount of projects and i'm
sure that you've learned so much about
you know software developments
challenges outsourcing and and how how
these types of companies interact with
with the living living and breathing r d
world so marius maybe walk me through
your own journey within romania and and
how you end up understanding that what
you want to be doing is creating this
software development consulting service
absolutely
my pleasure so um um i think i had my
first uh
computer around
10 or 11 years old and uh
i got hooked to it i mean uh you know
following uh algorithms and uh and
implementing and uh
making the whole machine work uh
was something that uh somehow fitted my
profile
my profile being again
from even earlier uh as you know i was
dreaming of a world where where i could
for example one very vivid dream i had
as a child was coordinating a set of
drones to fly
in any
formation and position and explore now
this is uh
if i'm sure you've seen the
demonstration with the thousands and the
of drones flying over parades and
everything like that so it's very real i
think we're living amazing tanks
so um
interacting with the computers was one
one one thing that uh uh you know i i
enjoyed
and uh from that point on you know the
career and
a strive for uh excellence a personal
strive for excellence was something that
has driven me and that drive you know uh
um
for example i don't believe in part-time
i'm i'm not a fan of part-time i don't
think uh doing uh
a part-time job in x or y would
help you
achieve you know higher standards and
higher goals
tell me a little bit about that maria
before we continue in journey i think
this is an important topic to discuss uh
you know today's generation my
generation the millennials we we love
taking on a few different projects
and and and seeing how we can become
because there's so many opportunities
today so what is your take on part-time
versus full-time and why do you why do
you think that
well um
i would rather say that for me
personally uh and
i think it's true or valid for many many
other people
um
doing um
how do maybe we should use the term
meaningful uh work uh or deep dive uh
those are also terms that relate to to
the idea of part-time whenever your
attention is
split in multiple ways i think uh
you aren't achieving your uh
let's say your best um
you aren't
exploring the depth of the domain deep
enough
and when i'm talking about the depth of
domain uh
for example uh um we are 600 in the
organization and uh but the level of
refinement in analyzing the uh let's say
internal
data let's just use a generator data
is uh to such a high level because of
this deep dive
let's say type of work
that i i don't think
doing it
part time or in any other way would
would you one would achieve this this
sort of of sophistication let's say
so that's my uh my my concept i think
only if you did dive you you would
reach
level of
sophistication now from your perspective
is that is it mainly an issue of of the
amount of time that you spend is it the
the focus that your brain needs to get
to to be able to really understand the
problem and and come up with this with
the right solution
what are the limitations of part-time
that that maybe inhibit you from from
achieving that same level of
sophistication
um then should i maybe maybe apparel
it would be like uh doing yoga
or meditation but uh listening to music
at the same time
so
i think uh yeah when the attention is uh
split uh you know you you lose some of
the things
you would otherwise
achieve
through i know techniques like uh
transcendental meditation for example
like the one that you know a lot of ceos
are using and so on
uh if that makes sense
no no that makes a lot of sense okay
sorry i stopped you continue please on
on your own journey leading up to
tremendo absolutely
basically my my focus was uh uh
in the early years
to the point of for example i i used to
to
play in a
national basketball championship uh we
used to be national champions as well
but
whenever
i had
at the moment i had to make a choice i
decided i have to make a choice between
you know also doing sports or doing deep
dive on my
on my i.t career and i clearly choose it
just has chosen my my i.t career
but
at that time
i felt that this is a very clear choice
should i do this should i split my
attention in into two because trainings
with the with the team were taking a lot
of time you know like every day
a few hours or should i you know just uh
go
full full head on with the
learning exploring building and
improving myself on it
so that's uh that's sort of like uh
the mindset i used to have at that point
and i still do
so um
at some point you and myself
got the opportunity to to work in
silicon valley along the many stanford
graduates and the whole energy of the
environment i think uh
um
infused us with uh with uh
with a
drive and a a need we already had a lot
of friends that were appreciating us so
guys we are doing great uh
very good uh
working and so on why don't you start
something so um
i think uh that was uh the catalyst and
that's when um you know the whole thing
sparked and from that point on you know
with the whole item market uh growing
and growing
especially in the last year for example
uh it was uh uh it was it was quite
clear
um there was one thing because we're
named in the region several years in the
room now the fastest growing
company
uh and uh maybe that's a differentiator
how did we
manage to to to grow so fast so
um
that was uh
you know
that itself is a story in which
we managed to find a recipe on how to
deliver more and more projects and um
um continue to attract people
uh high quality engineers uh very
top-notch engineers and uh and uh you
know build and deliver on those projects
so that was uh again another challenge
and now we're up to this point
so so two things that i'd like to focus
on and pick your brain on one is this
the romanian tech ecosystem you're
starting out in 2006 you're on you you
have this conviction that
the trend of i.t needs or is growing and
obviously you're right because 15 years
later you have more than 400 employees
and and more than 700 projects under
your belt and the second one is really
the question of growth so one you've
figured out sort of this recipe and sort
of this how does this thing work how do
you actually manage to keep it growing
at a fast pace while keeping the high
quality but let's start with the first
question about the romanian ecosystem
and and what what are we experiencing
today versus perhaps what also was there
in 2006 when you started this
um
my first job uh i was paid 70 bucks per
month
um so that was a 500 a month
yeah
that was a fun uh fun uh fun part i
think now the salaries in i.t uh in
romania at least are
on average a bit higher than uh than
spain
for example so
the the level of demand is at an all
times high
[Music]
and
the story is probably quite simple
romania has a a very um
i mean the the soviet influence or the
russian influence back from uh from
those days
um uh you know um
pushed us as
driving our educational system to uh to
form very uh
technical guys focus on mathematics and
uh other exact science was uh sciences
were
characteristic of
and are still our characteristic of the
educational system
um
now um
our luck let's say in the whole story is
that
we are probably the largest country in
the region in
eastern europe
and um
the fact that we did
uh you know had this uh push towards the
the us and try to to break ourselves
from the russian influence and
fortunately were at that point
created a whole culture in romania a
more let's say western type of so you
know people are looking at western
models
of course there are influences from the
region from the volcanic area and so on
but uh the fact that we are very western
in mindset and so on and with the pretty
big
it labor force
uh helped us being
one of the favorite destinations let's
say in in terms of you know developing
i.t
projects and so on
so um
clients from western europe for example
uh when deciding to to make an
investment to being i don't know ukraine
or the former soviet bloc
or other countries in the region um you
know the the
the choice is sometimes quite simple now
there are variations and that there have
been variations through years in which
uh
maybe at some point we are more
expensive than other countries but then
other countries caught up with the with
the pricing and so on
but right now
an educated buyer if
one is looking at choosing where should
i uh
you know develop my projects in which
country
this uh cultural factor is is a pretty
strong one in favor of romania
and with an output of uh
i know some uh
dozen thousand engineers per year i
think wow and with uh yeah i think the
latest quotes or around two hundred
thousand uh it specialists
uh you know that yeah it's uh
it helped us uh and i think the 8
industry is
probably the largest contributor right
now uh it used to be the second i think
is the largest contributor i know to the
gdp of the rain in gdp
wow so tell me a little bit about
tremend itself and how you're how you're
thinking through the growth of recent
years so beyond you know finding a
product market fit and and and finding
the right way to work with these
different with these different clients
how do you manage to keep growing at a
fast pace to be named
you know over several years the fastest
growing tech company
that that used to be um
that that is still uh and used to be a
very big challenge
i think um
um
most businesses are people businesses
not just
the services the sector like um like
professional service sector like
ourselves
um
and uh
um for example um
one of the pillars of this growth was
the fact that
as a
culture our company you know
try to to to attract
also people not just very good technical
uh
you know experts and so on
um especially in the i.t sector where a
very good engineer
you know sometimes you know if you spend
too much time with the code and the
screen you know that's where your skills
are so um
by developing also your human uh yeah uh
interaction skills and so on it's uh
it's a matter of time we replace your
time you know
and um
yeah i think uh that created a bit of a
snowball effect i mean constantly the
feedback about us in various polls and
so on is that the team is great that
it's very nice to work there and
learn from others and so on and that
helped us attract more and more
uh uh
on the other hand on the other side of
the or
on the other side the working with
clients and having let's say uh people
that it's nice to interact with
uh created the the same kind of effect i
mean clients saying that okay these guys
are good and it's also nice to interact
with them
um
that you know also sparked the the
demand
and um
probably
i'm going to switch to a bit of a bit a
bit of a different topic but uh
probably um
there's a match uh if you've read the
ray dalia's principles and
and the concepts of radical transparency
and so on i think uh there's the
there's a lot of overlap
between uh the culture that uh uh
regalia is describing his book and what
we're doing here so
um you know admitting to the mistake
trying to fix and having a positive
attitude instead of you know
masking the error tricking the customer
and so on uh
created this uh
okay
maybe because everybody makes mistakes
maybe if these guys made a mistake uh
but they admit to him they work to it
you know that that's making things uh
nice and pleasant so
yeah that created uh a whole uh
a whole um you know supply and demand
let's say uh stream
and the uh one good news this month so
like one week ago
we had the
42 new colleagues joining in one day
wow yeah
that's uh
it's no by no means that uh you know
accenture levels on but 42 is like uh
almost like a an entire company so that
was very very nice
unbelievable 42 a new employees in one
day
no wonder your name that one of the
fastest growing tech companies in
romania and again i guess in europe in
the world because i i i don't know i
don't know how many companies are on
boarding 42 42 employees in one day and
i i don't even know how that's possible
while maintaining this culture of
integrity of excellence and and and it
sounds like what you're doing with
tremendous is really it's really
fascinating and your and you know your
attitude towards the towards building
this company and the ecosystem i think
is just really inspiring and so and
maurice i really want to thank you for
coming i have a few more questions about
about yourself more and i want to take
you back to your childhood i want to
take you back to before you know perhaps
in basketball or in sports or anything
else what really fascinated you what
drove your curiosity as a child
um
i think
[Music]
so one of my favorite games of the child
was uh you know um
back in those days uh uh
real-time strategy games uh
weren't uh hype
uh there were no computers you know that
um so much and uh
trying to uh play with uh with
you know armies of uh various
uh types and you know running scenarios
and so on uh was one of my
most
deep and intense types of play
playfulness
and a game that i used to play
20 years forward i think uh
you know that uh that uh for
30 years world i think that uh uh
joy of of playing those games is still
reflected in what i do i mean i i
absolutely love my my job you know down
to the
very last minutes of work yeah
and uh there are more things yeah there
are more things but uh
that's that type of big play is
amazing and so what that's a great way
to what inspires you today in your daily
life in daily work
um
i think uh the i mean
there were certainly a very technical
aspect to my
formative years
and i used to be uh
and probably still um to some degree
very analytical and you know sometimes
forget a human factor but uh
as you progress through through the age
i think the the quality of the relations
um again following on the principles uh
book of red value the quality of the
human relations with the with your
with people around you let's say not
just co-workers but family as well is
something that uh creates um
a lot of of of reward and the
somehow the focus from solving technical
problems which i believe that you know
any technical problem can be solved with
enough time and so on uh focused more on
the let's say uh people problem trying
to understand how the
mind of of my colleagues work and
how the
mind of a social group works uh because
the dynamics within a group are
following the
i would say similar rules to one
individual but also uh they have their
own rules yeah so that that that type of
of uh dynamics and relationships is
fascinating me right now
amazing and what are three words you
would use to describe yourself
well um
i think uh
being driven is one of my main um
characteristics characteristic
striving for balance uh so balance is
working always uh
is like an alert a system that's
alerting me when you work too much or
you
stay too much on one topic and so on
and uh
somehow this
mindfulness so deep type deep dive
type of work whenever i go into
something i can you know
go to the very bottom of
it and uh still in general i can lose
myself in working on one topic
i mean marius thank you very very much
this was great
i really love what you're doing and and
i think there's so many lessons to be
learned from your journey and i really
thank you for coming and uh
[Music]